this character is the closest to
yourself you've ever played yeah in in
that I'm not really likely see mother of
dragons yeah
yes that's more I'm much closer to leave
definitely because immediately really
gave me phones which is everywhere it's
like a topper it's in every country but
my friends or friends of Lee but I
believe your parents Amelia we're bit
worried because you didn't have that
much to do in the first few episodes no
no yes yes so there's been some episodes
that maybe they're like no it was great
but you sort of not really on very much
are you but but then I did encourage
them to watch the last not this last
episode with episode before which in
hindsight might have been not the
episode to choose there's a lot of you
in that it seems a little bit yes there
was yes that might be the episode to dip
into me and I can really see how you're
doing
oK we've just got a faraway shot but the
camera did go right in there and did you
or did you watch it with your parents
give it a no right no no I mean did you
watch it with your parents yes that is
quite eggy yeah did you have to leave
the room or did you all just sit there
just gotta go
okay we're watching this yeah probably
started talking about something really
important like top gear
so we have to drive from London to
Blackpool in those a pet you know I know
but it is only for their benefit of
their there it was their shock not
others who was but who were